Nè, bụng chính bà người phân ngôn bộ trí quy trung ơn khá trao án án bị ra của ihan.
Ông ở bài hình, Joe Faigari, Cạnh Báo, vì tế tụi cuộc sông đầu giới văn với Mỹ về suy ra của thịt khiến
sát sợ còn câu tăng lên trên hai chương đôi là Mỹ một thông.
Theo, Nếu chiến sự kiếm sài và lắng giậm chung của trung đồng khi chúng năng lượng thế giới
sẽ chữ thật động mạnh.
Hoàn chức i ra này cho sang có khổ tấn công gần đây của Mỹ về suy ra, đáng nhắm vào một số
có sợ liên quan tới hạ tình như liệu và dịch bộ dân sự tại ihan.
Chục kỳ đó, một số nước vùng vình như thương án, bà rành, á lập xíu, cá ta và cái tử vùng của á lập thông nhất cho biết
các cơ sợ giới sự của họ trong đó cũng súng hạ tình năng lượng.
Đấy biện ngôn với các cuộc tấn công bằng tư luật tử ihan.
Tư khi xung đồng phát nhẹ hai Mỹ tăng tháng hai, sát sợ thịt sợ đất thăng mạnh sâu lông hạy gián đoạn
hủng công, đặc biệt tả tại iao biển hoặc ngôn, tuyến vẫn chuyển khoảng 25% lượng dầu và khi tự nhiên hoả lạng tăng cầu.
Theo các số liệu cân đây, sát sâu đã tháng lên khoảng 25% lượng là Mỹ một thông trong phíang xa dịch đô tòn.